I don't want to be political here, but let's just talk facts.
Barack Obama was wildly popular in Germany, wildly popular.
Didn't he give that speech before it was before he was president when to like a
million people or something.
Yeah. And he said, and he maintained his popularity. People loved him,
but he didn't get any of his signature programs or policies through.
And I mean that you look at tip,
which was the economic signature program of,
of the Obama administration. The Germans killed it.
They literally led the fight to kill it. Nordstrom too. We said,
don't build it. They went ahead and built it. Jacka Holly,
the Nazi prison guard, living in New York city for 12 years,
the us courts said, get them out of here. He lied to us.
We want them back in Germany, the Germans wouldn't take them.
The entire eight years of the Obama administration, they asked,
will you take this Nazi prison guard back? They ignored him defense spending.
We asked him very nice ways. Can you raise your defense spending? You know,
we think that you should be a better mate NATO member.
They largely didn't do it. And so all of those issues were,
were solved under the Trump administration.
So I've actually said to chancellor Merkel and to, uh,
the foreign minister and to others in Germany,
you're going to have to deal with some tough tweets.
You're going to have to deal with some pushing and some ribbing,
because the only way that we can read this is that the Donald Trump style has
worked.
So Trump. Okay. So let's just sort of piecing this all together.
Then now you have this guy who you don't have to walk that tight rope,
tight rope.
We had 17 candidates in the, uh, in,
in the primary and Donald Trump really just stuck out.
And so I was really excited to, to work for him.
I mean, look, this is a guy who,
who was very clear in the, in the campaign,
um, that, that he wanted to treat everybody the same. He really did.
And,
and so I liked working for him because he was challenging us on the Iraq war
implementation and saying, you know, uh,
I thought it was a disastrous decision. Um,
he was critiquing Bush and McCain and Romney's positions on the Iraq war
in a Republican primary. Now everybody around me had said, Oh,
he's done.
But that was all the Washington type people who were playing by the rules.
And if you took their rules, he would have been done.
But the primary is really about the people outside of Washington.
And that's where I felt like I was reading the situation better than what they
were, because my sphere wasn't what the Washington crowd was,
was saying about he's done. And, and he's not acting like a Republican.
It was what the Republican base or the people and how they were
responding to. Yeah, that's an obvious the Iraq war,
uh, management didn't go well.
And so that was an honest assessment of, you know,
some people say touching the third rail of politics of,
of saying the things you're not supposed to say. And I liked that.
But Rick, I don't understand. Everybody says,
if you listen to the mainstream media that everyone in the world,
they don't respect us anymore.
And they think he's a buffoon and all of these things could that possibly not be
true. I mean, that's what the New York times is telling us.
I'm really joking aside. Like, what are you, what are you seeing?
Like now as an ambassador,
when you go to all the NATO things and all the places you go to and all the
meetings, do you sense like that people suddenly don't respect us.
They used to respect us they'd own or were, or were not the Patsy anymore.
Perhaps like, what is the real.
So I think what you're really asking is does his style work or does it not work
right compared to Barack Obama style, which is much different?
I think we should be honest and say, we got two different styles.
Absolutely Washington rule making will tell you
that Trump's style does not work because he doesn't participate in what their
rules are. But let's look at that.
Let's look at whether or not his style works because I'll take this argument all
day long. I don't want to be political here, but let's just talk facts.
Barack Obama was wildly popular in Germany, wildly popular.
Didn't he give that speech before it was before he was president,
when was like a million people.
Yeah. And he said, and he maintained his popularity. People loved him,
but he didn't get any of his signature programs or policies through.
And I mean that you look at tip,
which was the economic signature program of,
of the Obama administration. The Germans killed it.
They literally led the fight to kill it. Nordstrom too. We said,
don't build it. They went ahead and built it. Jacka Holly,
the Nazi prison guard, living in New York city for 12 years,
the us courts said, get them out of here. He lied to us.
We want them back in Germany, the Germans wouldn't take them.
The entire eight years of the Obama administration, they asked,
will you take this Nazi prison guard back? They ignored him defense spending.
We asked him very nice ways. Can you raise your defense spending? You know,
we think that you should be a better mate NATO member.
They largely didn't do it. And so all of those issues were,
were solved under the Trump administration.
So I've actually said to chancellor Merkel and to, uh,
the foreign minister and to others in Germany,
you're going to have to deal with some tough tweets.
You're going to have to deal with some pushing and some ribbing,
because the only way that we can read this is that the Donald Trump style has
worked. Do you think.
Secretly like it, but sort of publicly? I don't mean Germany specifically,
but generally that countries and leaders,
they have to sort of pretend that they don't like Trump,
but as they see the U sort of reassert itself,
and maybe even as he forces them to pay a little bit more, actually pay their,
share that in a weird way.
They almost do like it because it helps give them a little bit of their
sovereignty back or, or a little ownership.
No, that's 100% for sure. Uh,
I think the publics in Europe,
like to have the ability to have their sovereignty back, they,
they love, uh, and, and president Trump has said this to chancellor Merkel.
I don't blame you for not paying your NATO bill and for buying cheap Russian
gas and having a $69 billion surplus over us and having a surplus
and 50,000 American troops protecting you. I don't blame you,
who wouldn't do that if you were the chancellor of Germany, but then he says,
but now it stops here because you outsmarted all these other presidents.
And now I have to stick up for my people. So.
Right. About all this stuff,
and now countries are paying more and all of these things, he is totally right.
Yeah. So granted, so, right.
So suddenly countries are starting to pay their share. Is it just,
is it just what you're saying?
That it was just the way Washington always worked and that it,
or is it just that we've refused to use any influence on countries
like that? We were just, it was just always easier to just be like, ah,
we'll pay for everything or, you know what I mean? Like.
Some of it is our own fault and you're getting out of that.
That's what, I guess that's what I'm asking that it was just,
we kept bringing in people that just were always like, Oh, we're paying them.
Yeah. And we've gotta be nice and all they're pushing back and we want to be pro
European. And, and so let's just have a dinner party and, and, you know,
a lot of parties yeah. And sitting in European capitals and really, you know,
we spent,
we have all of these people in European capitals working at our embassies.
I look, I think our embassies should be many commerce sections. You know,
I've got a whole bunch of people at the embassy who are super smart and,
and very committed to the United States and do great public service.
But I have come to the conclusion that having the whole team of people watching
the German political system and reporting back to Washington,
by writing cables about what's happening in,
in the governor's race minister,
president's race in a state in Germany and all of that stuff. Super interesting,
completely irrelevant.
In many ways we can get that information off the internet after it happens.
We don't need reporting officers to do that.
What we do need are economic specialists on LNG, liquid,
natural gas or economic specialists on medical devices to help us get
us companies growing in Europe.
I think that our embassies need to be transformed last on the political side.
Last about the politics of the country that we can get through the internet.
All this was established before we had the internet,
and now we need to turn these, uh,
these embassies into America, first economic models,
just like what other countries do. Um,
we're the only country in the world that gets in trouble for pushing ourself
forward. Everybody's doing it,
but we're the one that gets in trouble for saying, Oh, how dare you?
Yeah. Did you, by any chance read that book that I've got right there?
You Rome Harvoni the virtue of nationalism. No. Uh, because his whole,
his whole idea of which one is Mary's though. Oh, there you go. Well,
there's plenty of, there's a couple of good Douglas Murray books over here, but,
uh, the,
the basic premise of the book is that strong nations that you have to be a
strong nation first. So be America first be Germany first,
be whatever your country is first. And that's how you,
by being a strong nation first,
then you can create some sort of international community that makes sense.
But that really we're just doing it all backwards.
Or we've been doing it backwards for decades,
which is we put ourselves down and the thinking that we're achieving some higher
goal or something, and then we're ended, we ended up screwing over it.
Yeah. I think that makes a lot of sense. And, and, you know,
sometimes you have to be able to put forward in a,
in a pushy way, your position in order to get things done.
And that doesn't mean that the relationship is ruined,
but it just means that this is a priority.
And so you're going to push it harder. Um,
I think that's been one of the problems that we've had is just this kind of
status quo. Let's all, you know, you're supposed to say what you want.
And I'm supposed to say what I want. And then we,
we kind of cut the baby in half and we go away and go to lunch. And to me,
that's not diplomacy. I mean, we have to be able to push forward our agenda,
by the way, I've never,
I've been in thousands of diplomatic discussions, thousands.
I've never been in one where the other side doesn't ask for something.
And we ask for something in return, happens all the time.
This is called diplomacy. What do you want, what do I want? You know,
it's this whole thing.
And the idea that you're asking for something is not a quid pro quo,
it's called diplomacy.
This is exactly what we do is we show up to a meeting and we give our agenda of
what we'd like you to do and what we need.
And then you do that and we pick and choose. And when you make it a priority,
this is what I would say on the jacket, poly, the, the Nazi prison guard thing.
Uh, when I showed up in Germany and I made this a priority, and I said,
this return of the Nazi prison guard,
I brought it up in my first meeting with the foreign minister.
And you know what the foreign minister said to me after I brought it up,
I've never heard of this case. I mean, that's incredible.
The state department had told me, Oh, we've asked for 12 years. It's,
it's going to go nowhere, but you should bring it up. I,
in my Senate confirmation, I got a written question. Will you make DACA,
Polly, the return of the Nazi prison guard? Will you make it a priority? I said,
yes. And I, and I did it. And then president Trump said to me,
you should really get that Nazi prison guard returned. And I'm like, I'm on it.
I brought it up in every meeting. I made it a priority,
had to educate them. They returned them.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.